all i have now is this
my prime radiant this is the means by
which psycho history can be computed
through which every equation in my plan
may be analyzed
all here in this amazing small black
cube what i see before me around me
is the future of humanity 30 000 years
of potential chaos
compressed into a single millennium hey
guys pete here
today i'm going to look at isaac
asimov's fictional science of psycho
history with the upcoming apple tv plus
series i decided to explain this in the
most spoiler-free way
i'm gonna focus on how it was introduced
in the original foundation stories
and at least for now stay away from the
conclusions in history that azimov
tacked on when he came back to revisit
the series in the 1980s
not because those things aren't
important but because they give away
some important information that could
take away from the
ending in simple terms psycho history is
the mathematical study of the course of
humanity
it looks at how large groups or mobs of
people
react in response to things like
economic and social stimuli
in modern terms we would think of it as
a data science
that can be used to generate
probabilistic predictions
of future events this doesn't work on
the level of individuals
asimov modeled the concept on the
kinetic theory
of gases in his own words he described
it like this
the molecules making up gases moved in
an absolutely random fashion
in any direction in three dimensions and
in a wide range of speeds
nevertheless one could fairly describe
what those motions would be on the
average
and work out the gas laws from those
average motions with an enormous degree
of precision
in other words although one couldn't
possibly predict what a single molecule
would do
one could accurately predict what
uptillions of them would do
so i applied that notion to human beings
each individual human being might have
free will
but a huge mob of them should behave
with some sort of predictability
and the analysis of mob behavior was my
psycho history
it's a social science and later in his
career
asimov conceded that he should have
named it psychosociology instead
but at the time he was so intent on
using the word history because he got
the idea for the story
from his second reading of edward
gibbons the decline and fall of the
roman
empire the mathematician harry selden
spent his life developing psycho history
and in the process learned that it
predicted the fall of the galactic
empire harry developed what would become
known as selden's plan to shorten the
human suffering
in the gap between the fall of the first
and the rise of the new empire
this is what he's referring to in the
reading i opened the video with
psycho history predicts that after the
empire falls
that will be followed by 30 000 years of
chaos and barbarism
if applied the selden plan can shorten
that to 1 000 years
by accelerating the pace of developing
the second empire
which is guided by the foundations
right around here you might be thinking
that psycho history can
solve all of humanity's problems and
usher in utopia
it would actually make for a pretty doll
story if you think it through
where things start off in the original
trilogy is that psycho history
and the selden plan have been developed
but the fall of the galactic empire
that's too far along to be prevented
this is made more complicated because on
the surface
things seem to be going fine especially
for those that hold
power in the empire nobody wants to hear
or believe what harry selden has to say
and to keep things interesting asimov
added some logical
axioms that are necessary for psycho
history to be effective
selden himself established the original
pair of these
the first is that the population whose
behavior was modeled
should be sufficiently large this
reinforces that it can't be applied to
the actions of individuals
or situations involving small groups
within a population
second that the population should remain
in ignorance
of the results of the application of
psycho-historical analyses
because if it is aware the group changes
its behavior
this is where things get interesting and
where most of the tension in the first
book comes from
you can develop a plan but telling too
many people how it works
undermines its effectiveness this is
because
it works best with a limited amount of
independent variables
and where free will is somewhat
constrained to put it simply
people have to agree to follow a plan
that they don't understand more or less
blindly
and then it's gonna take several
generations before it's realized
it's not a spoiler to say that
foundation covers a lot of ground time
wise
it moves through more than three
centuries over the first three
books while it doesn't make it to the
thousand year mark to see the conclusion
of selden's plan
the final book in the series
chronologically foundation and
earth takes place nearly 500 years after
harry seldon dies
in that time new axioms are added to
keep up with the twists that asimov
introduces to keep things interesting
after all if everyone just followed
psycho history
and everything went smoothly it wouldn't
be very exciting
and it also wouldn't much resemble the
humanity that we know
if the tv show lasts long enough to
produce the seven seasons they're hoping
for
we'll get to see how the existence of
psycho history affects things
and how seldon's plan unfolds for the
foundations
there are two of them and harry set it
up that way from the beginning
and although i guess that's a different
video altogether
it is worth mentioning that the two
foundations are set up to
operate independently with the second
doing so
in secret so while harry isn't telling
very many people
what he knows is in store for humanity
psycho history does provide a plan that
gives them the best
opportunity to make it to the point
where the second empire is established
the plan also recognizes that there will
be crises along the way
so even though harry selden isn't
immortal he does die of old age early in
the
story he has things set up or he can
still
influence the foundations at key moments
in their development
in the show you'll see how he manages
that when they reach the first predicted
crisis
in a video like this i guess it makes
sense to ask the question
is psycho history something that could
work can we see something like this in
the real world
your guess is as good as mine if you go
looking for them
there are plenty of essays discussions
and debates out
there you can find arguments for and
against psycho history being viable
i lean towards the skeptical side i
don't think that we'll ever
see anything that works as precisely as
psycho history i like the idea it
develops an
interesting situation and i especially
like seeing how different characters
react to that
over multiple generations basing it on
the kinetic theory of gases is a novel
idea
but are molecules and people comparable
the human brain
the human condition and behavior it all
seems too complicated to express
mathematically
then again if humanity is still around
in 20
000 years who's to say to be fair when
he came up with this concept
personal computers were a long way off
it's interesting to see how things have
developed in data science but the
applications don't seem to be moving in
that direction
either way it makes for an interesting
series of stories
so it doesn't matter if it ever becomes
a reality
one last thing in the passage i opened
with it mentioned the prime radiant
that's the device that
stores the psycho-historical equations
which show the future development of
humanity it's basically a big map of
what's going to happen
the equations are projected and the
operator can zoom in to look at the
details and even change things
it is the psycho-historian's tool and
there's only a few of them out there
and i think that's a good place to leave
things it looks like the show's going to
be airing on
apple tv in september there's no
official release
it yet though that might mean we'll get
a full trailer
soon maybe next month and i can't wait
to see that
you still got time to dip into the book
so i'll put links to those in the
description
i think at this stage you'd have to
start with the book foundation
and then finish the original trilogy
from there you could decide if you
wanted to go into the robot series or
how you wanted to approach
the books that came out in the 80s the
one strong
recommendation i would make is to not
read the foundation prequels until last
the second prequel forward the
foundation is the last book asimov
wrote before he died and that adds some
weight to ending the series with it
it also brings things full circle in a
satisfying way
and there really isn't any reason i can
think of to read it in chronological
order
unless you just want to diminish the
mystery of harry selden
and get spoiled on how the series ends
at the very beginning
i reread all 15 books this year
including the empire series which isn't
completely essential
and that's a big investment of time so
it'll all depend on how much you want to
get into it
let me know what you think in the
comments if you have questions about
psycho history or about the series let
me know
if you've already read the books what
are you most looking forward to seeing
if you want to talk spoilers that's fine
but just mark those accordingly
don't give away the twists please like
this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon